we are going to look at weekend campaign
events involving Ron DeSantis Ron Des
sanctimonious
um Nikki Haley uh who else will get to
Pence we're going to start with Trump
Donald Trump had a town hall event on
Fox News in Iowa the event was so bad so
humiliating that even the friendliest of
friendly Fox News hosts Sean Hannity
could not save Donald Trump if you want
to see what a cult looks like it's Trump
entering the room to this
okay so those are cult members as you
can see I'm finishing up Vincent
bugliosi's book about the prosecution of
the Manson Murders many many many many
many many many many many
similarities between uh the family as
Manson's followers were called and
Trump's followers Trump bringing up uh I
mean listen I dare I'm not even going to
tell you what he brings up because I
don't know I dare you to decode this
clip from Trump during the town hall
oh boy
and the clip is glitching badly let's
hope we don't have this this would
become a humiliating segment hold on
here we go then your soldiers believe me
that's going to be like the greatest
deal you've ever made is to give us the
28 000. and they gave us 20 at that 8
000 soldiers free of charge and they
stop people you know they have no rules
that you're not allowed to talk fresh to
somebody or they put you in jail for the
rest of your life these soldiers are
tough soldiers in that sense so are ours
but our soldiers are told to do things
that are horrible I I'm it's I'm as
clueless as you are about what he's
talking about if you speak a little bit
harshly can you imagine if you go back
to MacArthur and you go back to some of
these tough generals they wouldn't be
able to be thrown out of the military
how about Patton yeah we used to slap
slap them around you get out there and
you three people clapping about patent
slapping people she wouldn't she would
have been out within two days he would
have been out of the military uh look
we've gone we've gone so bad it's it's
so sad what's happened yep okay
completely unintelligible word salads
and the crowd just cheers for anything
anything he says the crowd cheers for
Trump did make an interesting claim
Trump says that he uh got CNN to do his
town hall at 8 instead of nine
specifically to not compete with his
friend Sean Hannity and take away
ratings isn't that something you get
their best rating in 11 years that's
pretty good you know normally
[Applause]
success so they got their best ratings
and they want to fire the head of CNN so
it's supposed to everything is like
April Fool's Day nowadays right you get
good ratings it's supposed to get a
bonus right and you know what I did I
said I'll do the show but I'm not going
against Sean Hannity is that correct
that's why I was on at eight o'clock
they had me at nine I said wait a minute
nine but John's on Nine I said nope I'm
not doing it they said well then we'll
call it off I said I don't care they
wanted to do it I didn't want to do it
they said we'll do it at eight now how
nice is that right there you go nice
little favor to Sean Hannity and as with
most of these stories number one
completely irrelevant to whether Trump
would improve this country as president
and number two we never know whether
these stories are fabricated whole cloth
or whether there's even a grain of Truth
to them Trump reacting to Ron DeSantis
claiming he'll have eight years to
improve the country Trump's saying you
really don't need eight years I only
need six months people say oh you can't
it's just like
when I hear the Sanctus when I hear the
sanctimonious come and say we need eight
years
again if he needs eight years don't vote
for him I'll have that this country will
be hopping in six months and a lot of
it's going to do with energy
it'll be happening in six months unless
you know what's funny Trump could become
president and then on the day of the
inauguration January 2025 if the economy
looks like it looks now Trump will just
point to the existing numbers he'll say
look unemployment's so low black
unemployment so low wages are up
inflation's down stock market steady
there is no of course the economy will
be hopping in six months
because the economy is doing fine right
now could we have a recession a
depression of course we always could but
this idea that it's a disaster and Trump
will fix it laughable laughable idea
Trump then pulls out this claim that
he'll end the ukraine-russia war in 24
hours Hannity actually says how will you
do it and as you can see very shaky
Trump's going Trump's got the talking
point down I'll end the war in 24 hours
he needs to figure out what to say when
people ask him how will you do that but
I want to stop the War I don't want that
war to continue and I'll stop that war
mark my words I'll stop that war in 24
hours
but we're in a position
the only way he could stop in 24 hours
would be to force Ukraine to fold I
can't think of any other way he could
end it in 24 hours
Mr President let me ask
serious question how do you stop that
war in 24 hours I know both and frankly
uh zielinski was very good because they
you know he was part of the phone call
and he said he didn't say anything wrong
to me the Democrat he could have gone in
grandstand and said well I felt
threatened I felt threatened he didn't
I get along with him I get along with
Putin it's it would have been much
easier to stop it before it started
Putin would have never done this would
have been much easier right now it's a
mess now they're hitting Kiev and
they're hitting all sorts of things that
weren't supposed to be hit right the
country is being decimated by the way
the deaths are far more than their
report you know when they say nine if
you're waiting for the answer it's not
in here an apartment houses got knocked
down and two people got hurt there's no
no hundreds of people died the the
numbers are much different than what
you're being told I will get them into a
room and they will and I know an exact
way number one you tell one
you're not going to get anything unless
you make a deal you tell the other one
they're going to get a lot unless you
make a deal and you just sit them and
you put them and you have to make a
determination
the crowd convinced by this completely
unintelligible meaningless explanation
from Trump as to how he will broker
peace between Ukraine and Russia within
24 hours Trump also during this deranged
Town Hall taking credit for ending Roe v
Wade which by the way was not a very
popular change with the majority of
Americans I don't know that I'd be
bragging about this this might be why
Republicans didn't do so well in the
2022 midterms I didn't think when I
started my radio career in 1987 I'd be
talking a lot about but uh education
kids gender identity classes CRT uh I
never thought we'd really have this deep
debate about whether or not biological
men could be playing in women's sports
when you so crazy on all of these issues
you know what is the best way that you
see to settle well I did something that
nobody thought was possible I get rid of
Roe v Wade and by doing that
[Applause]
it puts pro-lifers in a very strong
negotiating position now they're
negotiating different things and you
know I happen to be of the Ronald Reagan
School in terms of uh exemptions where
you have the life of the mother rape and
Princess mother's life so you have that
and I think you know for me that's
something that works very well and for
probably 80 85 percent because don't
forget we do have to win elections but I
did something that nobody could do and I
also made them the radicals because they
are willing and able to kill babies in
the ninth month they're willing to kill
babies that's radical pro-life isn't
radical okay so this is crazy stuff of
course it's all untrue but if I were
Trump I don't know that I'd be bragging
about ending Roe v Wade given the
unpopularity of that decision and then
lastly here is Trump again
unintelligible I guess talking about
documents uh and Chinatown I don't know
I mean these these rants really are
putting uh putting linguists through
their Paces I have the right to
declassify as president he's
said he doesn't want anyone to see he
had seven or eight boxes in Chinatown in
Washington DC where nobody even speaks
English in Chinatown Chinatown is very
it's it's in favor of China yeah they're
Chinatown is it's in favor of China so
even with the most friendly questions
almost no pushback other than like oh
like how would you end the war in 24
hours Trump unable to coherently put
together a policy Vision there's nothing
he's not articulating any policy Vision
other than the sanctimonious is bad and
Joe Biden's bad and so on and so forth
now if you thought that the fox Town
Hall was bad
just wait until you see Trump's speeches
one of our sponsors today is replace
your mortgage mortgages are a really
interesting thing in the United States
the poor often can't afford them and the
rich often don't use them instead the
wealthy use special Financial tools to
pay off their debts often in a fraction
of the time that it takes for a
middle-class American to realize that
same payoff replace your mortgage
teaches you how you can pay off your
home in five to seven years without
needing to make more money than you're
currently making right now and in
addition they can teach you how to
better utilize your existing assets and
Equity to beginner continue growing
wealth and passive income through
additional strategies and they actually
have an upcoming Workshop that will show
you how you can take advantage of these
strategies how it all works create your
own economy in a sense you can go to
replace your universe city.com slash
Pacman to watch the interview I did with
their founder Michael Lush to learn how
you can get exclusive access to what can
be a life-changing virtual event the
link is in the description